yeah second oh my gosh
who the [ __ ] plays that bad I want to
grapple only keep getting now Rockets I
can change so we can do rocket only if
you guys want I don't care
it's whatever all right I'm sorry I
didn't mean to be mean to you guys is to
say I don't like yeah I don't like
myself in this situation [ __ ] it your
inner color duty players coming out I
can't help it
how about we progress here probably do
like that
I see oh yeah the spikes forgot about it
if spikes are still there yeah
the level flipped and that's like uh is
like a new level it's man no oh yeah
okay every box why not I don't know
where I'm going I don't know they were
impossible I don't like this experience
Oh God
I don't know what I'm going alright then
alright I guess I'll go here no Jesus
that's really close oh no nine nine good
night German he's always none oh yeah
I'm acting like one at least he's a
moose now you racist Oh any time
Oh for [ __ ] it how did he how do you
know
shut up don't you say a word I'll
destroy
your homeland awful [ __ ] sake don't
grapple the Nami runs ok grapple should
we sit over [ __ ] sakes perfect I don't
know
no I'll have to censor this video yeah
Oh for [ __ ] sake I'll for [ __ ] sake
god
I'll bet Freddie hell of it there
Elsa Swedish don't don't even don't even
know oh you try to grapple me while
you're dying low low all right cry I
know what you're thinking and I know
what you want and I love chocolate too
so don't even worry about it
I miss that many feet that what does
that mean kids it means I love you know
it know in front it doesn't in French
yes okay
where you going then Hey Oh be like Rob
call today I'll drag myself onto the
spike
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why me I'm so nice you guys are so rude
[Laughter]
it's good oh ho
every time we can what happened you used
to be good bra I have to plan the
monitor that's farthest away from you
it's kind of hard to see oh okay you're
gonna be that guy okay yeah just work
beat you guys Oh for [ __ ] sake oh you
son yourself
yeah can I hurt myself well that's life
for you bye oh do you mean for [ __ ]
sake what the hell was that that's how
you sound to me right now
come on taun taun and lazy
did you talk about what do you know time
doesn't exist dude even Tom bruh I don't
apparently he's loading screens are
great let's see if we can not get mirror
grab pods oh it's happening oh I'm sorry
I fling hex alright great what I even on
the ground I'm gonna baby you found the
ground [ __ ] watch out for the spikes oh
god someone got a grapple well thanks
for opening that little grappling hook
from your problem well for [ __ ] sake
for [ __ ] sake I can say hey how am I
still alive oh god I gotta talk see
that's because I was in the corner that
host advantage hey it's not a hose
advantage unless you have it this
grappling hook thing is like this
exciting yeah cuz there's not a lot of
item yeah an grabs yeah this looks
pretty bird
yeah maybe guy gets a [ __ ] grapple I
got it
don't let me go then there I did that
last time in it was no good don't
grapple me though cuz I'm busy oh oh
[ __ ] what I thought I would go up there
for some reason nah [ __ ] sake how many
times can you put a fucksake counter on
your [ __ ] I'm too lazy but okay if you
want me I'll do it
thank you you see that [ __ ] that's
pretty [ __ ] yeah mo [ __ ] Jean [ __ ]
come on wait up okay wait up just for
you just cuz you asked
Thanks oh hello what's that you got
there
it's a little something for your pet
hole why is this away I want to go
there's a terrible way to go why why is
that like a super high I went there last
I was terrible what what I don't even
say worried that's how you must have
been so super upset yeah second oh my
gosh who the [ __ ] plays that bad oh my
god it's my spirit and soul I think I
just lost I think I can five years of my
life or some [ __ ] what happened
I hit a box I think my my butt is like
made of iron so you couldn't grab on to
it
good meeting you lads but [ __ ] my [ __ ]
yard they actually helps you I think you
did thank you so sweet kitty doing there
what is he doing what is it
sorry I'm sorry sorry for everything
just remember me for who I was and not
who I am
now I don't go yeah [ __ ] sake [ __ ] sake
well who's got the grapple now the real
question is who wants to grapple who
wants to go who wants the grapple all
right bring it on like he's got the sly
[ __ ] what you [ __ ]
hell no I missed my only opportunity God
dang it box a duck in his anus don't do
that you might go to jail I'm not gonna
lose to you guys this is not happening
all right can take it now I gotta lose
oh my god oh my god he [ __ ] moose Oh
Jabba nada hello
what is that bomb on the screen Oh have
it starts the screen is gonna get
smaller yeah mom this game with three
seconds
[Music]
it's so serious right now
who wants it in the ass
no one was it a man Oh what okay
oh yeah it's on donkey calling
[ __ ] what how do you you son of
a ass I am you are I am going to slowly
choke yes sorry I'll take that back I
love you okay no I almost oh Jesus I
almost ran into that [ __ ] the other day
Becky god she's a [ __ ] you guys mean
didn't learn how to play if you're gonna
oh [ __ ] me
Fang does this game a little bit no they
didn't they don't give a goddamn about
this [ __ ] moose it's vibrating down
there for them it's mine is mine oh god
you guys need to be Swedish or some [ __ ]
cuz it's not working out oh god oh my
god oh god dang it got an achievement
because you guys [ __ ] suck how about
we do the last one and where ever wins
this wins everything I need your pity
win alright you know Randy who's gonna
grapple that anybody no oh my god you
guys [ __ ] oh [ __ ] sake wait up guys
Rayna oh really
wait up guys yeah the guy it's not
supposed to make it yeah that's the guy
lazer
oh damn blazer in your face sir
did you just say god dammit
yeah like oh god I got lasered there's
lasers and [ __ ] missiles get lasers
learn to tell the difference
nice rocket brah
watch out for the laser damn hey man
what are you trying to do there uh what
did that do this okay so why did I do
that you can if you if you if you yeah
if you watch the skies what is it
you slide if you slide you can dodge the
grapple oh well if you get killed you
can dodge it - just try to be nice
don't be nice okay take it in your ass
your walk really still at me okay I'm
gonna taunt you guys now that I win it's
gonna be awesome
what uh get super powered it's like
they're all some people okay oh great
that's useless
hey I needed that Oh God that laser
almost had me wait up cry wait up [ __ ]
I was dead
oh sorry hey how dare you okay you have
to win with the tongs how about that
that would that would be fair okay more
rules you want to make up you have to
wear makeup on Tuesdays alright I'm
taunting that's my taunt
oh you [ __ ] come back Oh was there
something you wanted to say and right
through it no because I'm pinky [ __ ]
I'm gonna to 100 I better stop we'd
better stop I think something bad is
gonna happen
I hope your YouTube channel like
attacked
I hope you lose everything you've
acquired over the years even I don't
know I hope I hope that me that Marzia
finds like a model like a really hot guy
Wow I'm saying I'm not high
just totally leaves you for him
totally leaves you for the hot guy hope
at night think about how she's with him
instead of you now the things you had
planned for the future just they're gone
Phoenix think what you could accomplish
without her yeah wait what the [ __ ] life
okay there's a difference here every
every clan is still providing us all I'm
saying alright and still open could
poops in your bed baby baby
[Applause]